the governor Ohio's doing a great job he
called that off and we'll see what
happens as a court case and it hasn't
been fully determined yet but if he
called it off I could understand that
because you know he he's definitely
somebody that knows what he's doing
we'll be seeing what very soon all right
that's when the President of the United
States and other Democratic leaders
saying the same thing about the governor
you're looking live that empty polling
locations in Ohio after governor Mike
Devine postponed the state's
presidential primary today the Ohio
Supreme Court backing the governor's
decision the Ohio Republican governor
joins us right now governor DeWine good
to have you thank you for coming
happy Saint Patrick's Day to you as well
sir let me get your if you can some
people say hon if you have to do this
and Republicans and Democrats seem to be
backing your move why did you put it off
we didn't want to put Ohioans at risk we
have 35,000 poll workers that takes to
put on an election as I'm sure our
viewers have experienced they're
wonderful people some have been doing
this for a long a long time some for
decades so some are some are older more
at-risk individuals so this is a disease
or this is a virus that sometimes people
can't tell they have it and so they can
be a spreader without even knowing that
so having our poll workers work for 13
straight hours they're just made no
sense it's also a risk to all those
people who are voting the CDC came up
with the regulations the day before
yesterday said no more than 50 people in
a room we couldn't even you know we
certainly could not conduct an election
that way and finally we didn't want to
really challenge our voters particularly
our voters who have a medical problem or
our voters who are over 65 to choose
between exercising their constitutional
right and and their health that just
doesn't make sense and we can do it we
can have absentee balloting go on for an
extended period of time everybody will
have the opportunity to vote
that wants to and that's that's really
what we should do you know governor I'm
just wondering that about the other
state scheduling primaries today our
zona in Florida Illinois are they making
a mistake look I wouldn't say that I
mean every governor who does what he or
she thinks is best for their state you
know governors are right there they have
to make that call
I would not criticize that call but I
made this call because it was clear that
this would put in jeopardy the safety of
Ohioans and look what we've learned from
this from the models that have been done
and all the experts in every decision
we've made has been based upon medical
science what we've learned is if you
don't intervene early in this you're
going to end up like Italy is today and
that's just very very tragic we had a
whole meeting today discussion about our
hospitals getting ready for this and you
know we're going to run out of equipment
we're going to run out of personal
protection gear for the doctors unless
we slow this down and it can't be this
curve that goes straight up like they
have had in Italy we've got to set up
you know shut it down a little bit
spread it out or we're going to be in
the same position Italy is and we don't
want to be there you know you don't you
know sort of lighten this entire virus
situation in Washington Post said of you
today sir that your announcement of this
was typical of your no-nonsense high
fact way in which you've delivered a
daily dose bad news saying of you that
you frequently cite the advice of public
health professionals that he doesn't
referring to you mention politics shows
his concern about the impact of his
choices which he's acknowledged could be
devastating for the economy he
sugarcoats nothing now I'm sure
political advisors have told you
governor when you're talking about some
of these tough measures and you've been
talking about long because they became
fashionable or at least common you took
a lot of political heat for that but you
didn't seem to care well I think I think
Ohioans really needed to understand the
truth and if I'm going to have any
credibility I need to be you know honest
with them I've got a great director of
health dr. Amy Acton who
really kind of led me through this we
have consulted with experts not just in
Ohio but all over the country and what
we've learned is you've got to move
early there's a classic case that I've
cited that I've read about in 1918
between st. Louis and Philadelphia
Philadelphia was only two weeks behind
st. Louis and what they did and yet the
death rate in Philadelphia was
dramatically higher than it was in st.
Louis so right eventually they did yes
the st. Patrick's Day Parade and they
went on it was too late two weeks later
was too late so it's this this stuff
multiplies and you know the number that
I'm told by the experts that the number
of people in Ohio and across the country
who actually have been affected that
number will double every six days so
just whatever the number is today it
doubles over every six days and that's
just crazy so we've got to we've got to
slow it down as much as we can so let me
ask you about that because the flipside
of a number that could grow
exponentially governor is that the
denominator changes things and the
number of fatalities I hate to sound
like this is is lower than we thought
and that some people look at that and
say well you know it's better stepping
back from it and seeing that your
chances of dying are much lower now what
do you tell them well you know we have
an obligation to move move quickly and
we know if we don't move quickly we're
going to see more people die that's been
the evidence in Italy that's been the
evidence throughout history we have
experts modelers who look at that and
look this may mean that we're in this
longer for a longer period of time but
we're gonna lose fewer people and we're
not gonna the other major problem that
people don't really talk about it look
at is what happens when our hospitals
overwhelmed if they are and we haven't
slowed this thing down and you have a
heart attack or you have you have needs
to cancer surgery or you need something
else you know those people are going to
be impacted adversely as well and we
worry about them as well as the people
who contract
you know this virus
the president seemed to indicate this
could be a July or August event before
you know this hits its ceiling or is
resolved there's no way of knowing of
course the president said as much a New
York Governor Cuomo has indicated 45
days he hopes before the worst of it in
New York but he and the mayor of New
York City governor are differing over
whether they have locked down tight
measures in New York City how do you
feel about going to that next level
where not only are you sort of
hibernating in your home so to speak but
it extends to not even leaving your home
period well we're not there yet in Ohio
we could we could get there we're not
there but what we're doing and I'm gonna
do it again right now
although hyoeun's who are watching this
if you can stay home stay home if you
could not work in your business but you
can work from home please do that for
anybody who's 65 years of age or older
do not have contact with with very many
people just try to confine that to a
very very small number of people because
the death rate goes up dramatically as
people get older so it's you know it's
not just what orders I make or my health
director makes you know what's really
important is how everyone takes care of
themselves because when you take care of
yourself you're taking care of your
family but you're also taking care of
absolutely total total strangers be very
very careful
keep that social distance away we have
to go about our lives but we have to if
we can we need to hunker down I mean I
know people who literally are in their
home now and they're doing everything
they can they'll go out maybe to get
groceries but they're doing everything
they can not to expose themselves to
other people and that's the way to get
through this I think you're right
governor very very clear very sober
about it no nonsense you know sugarcoat
it yeah they don't do overly make a
crisis of it it's a rare quality in a
Democrat or a Republican or anyone
that's to look governor thank you well
thank you very much good to be with you